[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes en direct
aujourd'hui pour ce qui devait
s'annoncer comme quelque chose d'assez
historique et le retour d'une capsule
vers la lune pour une première étape
pour autrui dans la lune et finalement
ça a été annulée reportée en tout cas on
va en parler avec notre invité cyril en
lv1 bonjour cyril rédacteur au service
science du figaro vous voyez cette
magnifique fusée qui est là qui est
assez massive il faut le dire on
reviendra un peu sur tout ça vous
n'hésitez pas à tout le monde cela il va
poser vos questions on y répond au mieux
comme d'habitude on va peut-être parler
de ce qui se passe cette fusée devait
décoller à 14h33 enfin le début de la
fenêtre d'ouverture c'était 4h33 et ce
sera pas le cas finalement non en fait
la nasa elle vient d'annoncer le report
du lancement et
cesser
c'est principalement dû à un problème
soir des quatre moteurs principaux on
voit sur l'image le corps central de la
fusée en orange c'est de la mousse
isolante et en bas en dessous il ya
quatre gros moteur très très gros
moteurs qui sont des anciens moteurs de
la navette spatiale j'ai été réutilisés
pour cette fusée est avant de l'allumer
avant les allumés il faut les refroidir
et trois des quatre moteurs sont bien
refroidi et le quatrième pas du tout
c'est un problème assez grave parce que
on n'allume pas un moteur chaud comme ça
il ya des carburants qui sont hyper
froid c'est l'hydrogène liquide à moins
de 150 degrés l'oxygène liquide - 160 je
crois tout ça se mélange dans le moteur
fusée et il faut que ça reste très froid
donc sauvera australien à ce que tu en
carburant arrive et que le moteur est
chaud
les métaux ont des réactions assez
brutale et ça peut ça peut exploser
aussi simple que ça
et donc le refroidissement il avait dû y
aurait dû être produit par un léger
excès de
l'hydrogène liquide mais un peu qu'ils
qui est dans le réservoir principal est
qui qui se dé gaz il est encore très
très froid et on le fait circuler dans
la dans le moteur la paroisse dans les
parois métalliques s'appelle la sarp
refroidissement actif qui est aussi
utilisé par un fonctionnement du moteur
pour éviter que ça fonde et sur un des
quatre moteurs ça n'a pas foncé n'a pas
fonctionné
l'objectif donc le report de au moins
plusieurs jours la prochaine fenêtre de
tir c'est le vendredi 2 à 18 heures mais
il faut que d'ici là le problème soit
résolu oui parce que un problème comme
celui là qui arrive ça peut prendre du
temps ça serait justement oui et la nasa
n'a donc 2
dit que l'objectif de la journée là
c'est de comprendre ce qui se passe et
de t'avoir le plus de données techniques
pour comprendre l'origine de cette de ce
problème est en fait là en fait donc
c'est un premier vol c'est un premier
vol d'essai il ya personnes à bord donc
les enjeux c'est vraiment testé cette
fusée qui n'a jamais volé c'est la fusée
la plus puissante jamais construite est
ce qu on va expliquer rapidement exaucé
quoi si tu dis que c'est quoi cette
mission artemis finalement artémise
c'est le sait le nouveau programme
lunaire de la nasa pour renvoyer les
hommes et des femmes vers la lune
artemis et c'est une une ds c'est la
soeur d'apollon apollon c'était le
programme apollo dans les années 60 70
et c'est la déesse de la lune artemis
est en fait voilà donc là le grand
retour sur la lune et on pense que la
nasa on verra d'abord une femme ont posé
le pied sur la lune donc déesse artémis
on est dans le symbole on est dans la
pro a à la fois le on prolonge les
exploits des missions apollo plus de
cinquante ans après et voilà on veut
faire revivre ça et pour aller sur la
lune il faut une fusée puissante et la
nasa a fait le pari de construire une
fusée à partir des éléments qui avaient
été ceux de la navette spatiale est un
vaisseau spatial elles ont été arrêtés
mis à la retraite au début des années
2000 faisait trop dangereuse
sur une 110 vols il ya eu deux accidents
mortels colombien et challenger des
problèmes vraiment qu'ils étaient liés à
l'architecturé la structure d'un avait
donc la nasa à dire on arrête c'est trop
dangereux et en revanche pour faire
cette fusée linéaire on a gardé les
boosters donc les deux éléments blanc et
grandes colonnes blanches convoi de
parts et d'autres cd en france on dit
propulseurs à poudre non c'est des
grands professeurs qui étaient déjà sur
les navettes le corps central il est en
orange pareil c'était on a dérivé du
coeur centrale qui était le grand
réservoir de la navette qui était passé
sous le ventre des navettes spatiales et
au dessus on a un état jugé avec des
moteurs classiques et où tout au sommet
on voit ça en blanc une petite capsule
la capsule orion votre la partie on va
dire qu'ils restantes qui sera tiré qui
va nous intéresser le plus finalement
alors parce que le décollage
effectivement c'est très important mais
la partie qui va nous intéresser le plus
c'est ce petit d'homme ans haut blanc et
et voilà la fusée au décollage il fait
2006 plus de 2600 tonnes de 1600 tonnes
je crois que c'est j'ai fait le calcul
c'est 33 airbus a320 pleinement chargée
au décollage d'accord donc il faut pas
puissance gros gros gros bébé et on ne
récupère en fin de mission la capsule
quand elle revient se poser sous
parachutes en mer ou 9 tonnes donc on
garde 9 tonne sur 2600 au décollage tout
le reste est jetable
c'est voilà c'est une fusée qui a coûté
très cher à développer qui a été il ya
eu beaucoup de retard et devait décoller
la première fois en 2010 est on est en
2022 on se rapproche du premier vol est
quand même là on y est presque on ait
cédé près de deux minutes là le compte à
rebours s'est arrêté à 40 minutes avant
le décollage donc c'est déjà pas mal
en fait la panne la panne qui dont ils
sont victimes aujourd'hui en fait il
s'est un peu rageant parce que c'est
quelque chose qui réduisent testé il ya
quelques mois pendant le dernier
dernière répétition au sol sur le pas de
tir il avait déjà amené la fusée sur le
pas de tir à cap canaveral il avait
commencé le remplissage il avait presque
fini le remplissage et pillé un problème
à la fin sur l'hydrogène qui sont pas pu
aller jusqu'au bout il reste est je
crois une mine 30 dans la chronologie
et comme le remplissage d'hydrogène
était pas terminée ils ont pas pu tester
le refroidissement des moteurs ce qui
est en train ce qu'est point le point le
point chaud aujourd'hui c'est un jeu
vilain jeu de mots mais c'est vraiment
ça le problème
donc ça va pas pu être testés dont
classe quelque part si le projet arrive
aujourd'hui à c'est assez logique c'est
que ça pas été vérifiée un passé et il
vaut mieux que ça soit esthétique ce
soit compris avant un décollage est ce
que c'est un échec de fait nos mains du
tout cas que ce que ce qu'incarne départ
quand celui-ci soit retardé non pour un
programme aussi majeur aussi important
aussi ambitieux d'avoir un premier vol
reporter comme ça il n'est pas annulé ce
n'est pas un échec c'est juste par
l'acea prendre quelques jours de plus
ça fait ça fait partie c'est normal ça
fait partie de la logique c'est pour ça
qu'il ya des
comptes à rebours avec une chronologie
très précises où il faut avant qu'on met
à feu des moteurs il faut tout vérifier
et c'est quand on voit la taille réfusé
c'est donc sans mettre ma vie et 2600
tonnes c'est une complicité incroyable
c'est normal qu'il est petit et des
petites choses un peu un peu imprévues
qui se déroulent et qu'on doive résoudre
enfin c'est c'est vraiment vraiment le
plus capé normale et encore une fois
c'est un vol qui est pas habiter donc il
n'y a pas d'enjeu ils n'ont pas de
rendez vous sur la lune ya pas de ses
parts dans 3 jours franchement c'est pas
très grave nous on est un peu déçu parce
que on attendait ça avec impatience mais
c'est vrai que c'est aussi une énorme
actualité dans le même temps d'autres ça
dépasse la science mais ça fait combien
de temps qu'on a pas eu un décollage
aussi la plaza le c'est vraiment le
premier vol d'une navette spatiale
c'était en 1981
c'était extraordinaire c'est
exceptionnel donc voilà on est 40 ans
plus tard et on a un lanceur tout
nouveau
qui qui qui va faire je crois que c'est
30 % de plus en plus son décollage de la
navette
voilà je sais c'est un c'est le retour
des américains aussi dans la dans une
conquête plus lointaines
depuis en fait depuis apollo depuis
dernier homme sur la lune c'était en
1912 apollo 17
en fait là l'exploration humaine usine
solaire elle ces contraintes à rester en
orbite autour de la terre la station
passé international c'est un projet
incroyable
mais on est à 400 km d'altitude 400
kilomètres séparent ils y ont donc on se
donne pas beaucoup de la terre quand on
est un autre noté thomas pesquet on
connaît il est extra dire ce qu'il a
fait mais mais ils étaient il est vrai
n'avait plus en plus loin et la lune
c'est quand même ne pas là de la
première étape avant d'aller beaucoup
plus loin c'est l'objectif vraiment que
tout le monde vise c'est mars mais mars
c'est tellement compliqué tellement cher
il ya des enjeux technologiques et les
défis à résoudre les telle fille comme
c'est pas résoudre aujourd'hui enfin oui
mais il faut avancer déjà pour aller sur
la lune pourrait alors ça c'est ça se
discute mais c'est le plan la nasa en
tout cas c'est allé sur la lune essayez
de faire une base de longue durée et
missions apollo c'était les séjours au
maximum de deux jours soit surface
lunaire
armstrong et aldrin c'était une heure et
demie 1 c'était après les missions
suivantes se sont un peu allongé donc
passer des nuits dans leur petit module
d'atterrissage mais on reste les séjours
hyper bref et qui n'ont pas eu de suite
à l'ambition c'était de rester au pôle
sud de la lune un endroit où il ya de
l'eau sous la surface de la glace donc
assez de deux ans qu'on pourrait
extraire pour faire l'hydrogène pour un
carburant pour revenir de l'oxygène de
l'eau tout ça enfin c'est donc c'est une
ambition qui est quand même beaucoup
plus conséquente qu'apollo l'idée c'est
d'avoir une base comme celle de l' iss
c'est à dire qu'il y ait des gens qui
soit stationné oui sur la lune et le
lait les premiers à en parler c'est l
agence spatiale européenne et il parle
de moon vilaj vilaj lunaire qui soit une
infrastructure permanente ouverte à des
collaborations internationales
et après je sais pas du tout si l'on
verra ça un jour parce que vu le coût
d'un lancement de sls la ss et la fusée
laquelle bâtir est ce qu on sait combien
ça coûte
on a le cou du global du programme mais
ce qu'on sait on a vu on la nasa a déjà
dépassé dépenser 20 milliards de dollars
pour la mise au point et après il y
avait tout ce coût des infrastructures
de la construction on estime mais iliad
il ya différentes estimations du coût de
lancement c'est entre 2 et 4 milliards
de dollars par lancement
donc s'ils ont dépensé quatre milliards
de dollars reprenant une fusée vers la
lune pour faire une base permanente je
suis pas sûr que les
naseaux même la nasa très très riche
avec un gros gros budget annuel et les
reins assez solides pour supporter ça
donc l'espoir après c'est après la celle
et le seeland losc c'est sa fusée
starship à ce qu'elle sera un jour
capable totalement utilisable pour aller
avec des capacités qui s'approche de
celle de l'espèce effectivement alors je
salue mensah laz qui nous rejoint et 307
qui nous unit pour un point
d'interrogation on a plus l'image valeur
attendent et on va vous remettre animal
vous inquiétez pas on va vous remettre
une image ici quelques temps oui puisque
forcément vu que ça c'est terminé on a
voilà on a pu imaginer on va vous
retrouver ça je fus nos activités le
flux n'a d'atv puisque cbi s'est laissé
la nasa qui nous fournit ces images je
vais retrouver ça d'un côté rapidement
alors j'avais trois sets ce qui posait
une question mais il n'y a pas il avait
juste un point d'interrogation du
convoyer parce que c'est comme question
avant donc vous n'hésitez pas à bien sûr
à poser une question on l'a dit donc 20
milliards et il ya six pay 6 est ce que
la nasa trike space x oui cette affaire
le
donc la fusée sls elle est conçue par la
nasa elle a été construite par les gros
industriels que sont boeing et northrop
le coup développement est complètement
dingue est née d'un autre côté la nasa a
passé un contrat avec ce p 6 pour le
pour l'alunissage pour produire le
module qui va poser les astronautes à la
surface de la lune
et donc ça c'était un contrat de 2,9
milliards de dollars de la nasa avec ce
p 6 pour fournir le vaisseau qui va se
poser sur la lune
le problème de ces prévue pour 2025 2025
ces trois ans elle est très vite le vrai
problème c'est que de starship le
vaisseau lourd de spécifique n'a
toujours pas décollé ils devaient
décoller cet été a eu son premier vol à
prendre le temps de la terre donc il ya
encore et encore beaucoup développement
à faire avant que elon musk incapable de
prouver qu'il est acquis là la fiabilité
nécessaires pour emmener les astronautes
de la nasa au départ il n'aura que deux
vers la lune donc le 2025 peu d'experts
qui croit cette chronologie à ce dessein
parce que 2022 là on lance le pr la
première il faut savoir aussi que dans
le module orion
savez le module we made you die absolue
la capsule orion dans la capsule orion
qu'ouvrier en haut il y avait des
mannequins oui et un petit mouton aussi
alors on voit où ça c'est intéressant
sur cette vue là on voit donc le drapeau
américain la tour au sommet la fusée
c'est la tour d'éjection en fait c'est
un quelque chose qui peut de temps après
le décollage n'est plus ce n'est plus
utile si en cas de problème au décollage
vu qu'on a quand même on a sur 2600
tonnes on a plus de 2000 tonnes de
carburant carburant et oxygène liquide
donc s'il ya un problème une explosion
décollage il faut être capable
d'extraire les astronautes loin de la
catastrophe et c'est à ça que sert cette
tour blanche n'a donc on voit des
cloches au sommet quatre cloches sont
qui sont des moteurs ont fait des
moteurs fusées qui sont prêts à
fonctionner donc sous la coiffe arrondi
on à la capsule donc est une version un
peu agrandi les capsule apollo des
années 60 avec beaucoup plus de place à
l'intérieur je sais pas si vous voyez
sous le logo nasa il ya un logo is a
woman agence spatiale européenne qui
fournit en fait le module de service
c'est le système qui fournit électricité
dont des panneaux solaires qui fournit
de l'oxygène par les astronautes qui
leur fournit en fait tout tout ce dont
ils ont besoin pour vivre dans le voyage
dans la lune donc ça c'est une
contribution européenne qui est modeste
budgétairement par rapport aux 40
milliards déjà dépensés par la nasa mais
qui est crucial pour pour la capsule
sans ce module il n'y a pas de capsules
dans la capsule en tout cas il faut
qu'on peut mettre la sono temps donc ça
sert à rien et voilà c'est la
contribution européenne et c'est ça qui
assure que pour les premières missions
habitées duras les astronautes op 1 1 au
moins un asado 20 pour le premier vol
même si dans les premiers vols dit
risque de rester en orbite autour de la
lune et regarder les américains
descendre se poser effectivement alors
on rappelle que thomas pesquet était
très intéressé pour faire 4 à thomas
pesquet il est il est tellement de la
salle de presse avec je crois un autre
astronaute qu'un instant aux allemands
et ils sont avec le patron l'agencé
spatiale européenne et sa présence pense
un joli symbole pour dire ben il est
plutôt en lice pour être dans les
premiers européens à partir au moins
autour de la lune pas forcément sur la
lune j'imagine qu'il y aurait au moins
autour de la lune par 2025 alors on à
tony poncet qui demandent si la diffuser
va décoller aujourd'hui non elle ne
décollera pas aujourd'hui christophe
quive lasserre reporté au plus tôt le 2
septembre il ya deux autres fenêtres de
tir c'est ça oui il ya le 2 septembre
vendredi soir à 18h ou alors le lundi
suivant lundi 5 septembre
si ça décolle pas à ce moment là il
faudra ramener la fusée dans son hangar
et les ça prendrait pour pas mal de
vérification donc ça prendra plus de
temps mais le le report et l'angoissé au
plus tôt le 2 septembre mais c'est pas
sûr du tout il faut d'ici là que la nasa
comprennent le problème comprennent
pourquoi ce moteur 3 sur les 4 ne se
refroidit pas est ce que c'est
une valve qui coince et est ce que ces
gens seraient bien oui bien sûr on donc
là c'est l'objectif de la journée c'est
pour la nasa c'est de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi un des trois
handicaps moteurs
n'a pas reçu le flux d'hydrogène pour le
refroidir voilà je sais c'est frustrant
parce que parce qu'on attendait ce
lancement avec impatience mais en même
temps c'est pour une fusée aussi
complexe aussi ambitieuse aussi cher on
pouvait s'attendre à des choses comme ça
c'était franchement oui oui quand on
demandait aux spécialistes qui disait ya
quand même peu de chances que ce soit
l'école à l'heure du premier coup je
salue christian léon toussaint qui nous
a rejoints dans le chatt bovary qui ont
dit où en est la france dans cette
course à la lune est ce que la france
est dans cette course à la lune déjà à
bas la france elle est avec l'agencé
spatiale européenne donc le plus gros
ainsi la france est l'un des principaux
contributeurs au budget de l'agent
social open donc sur le module de
service
oui il ya des grosses contributions
françaises
après
voilà la france non on n'a pas de
programme
la france en fait elle a un peu hélas un
peu comment dire échaudés par l'échec de
ce navet la petite navette qui
s'appelait hermès dans les années 90 la
france avec l'ambition balancer les
astronautes ou sommet d'une fusée ariane
et ça a été assez difficile le projet
devenu de plus en plus compliqué et il a
dû être abandonné transféré d'abord
l'agencé spatiale européenne et puis
finalement abandonnée parce que c'était
trop compliqué on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait trop de contraintes de
sûreté qui au final n'y avait il pas la
performance nécessaire pour emmener les
astronautes à bord de marianne mais les
vols habités en europe c'est toujours en
collaboration avec les américains avec
les russes aussi pour la station
spatiale internationale donc thomas
pasquet il a fait les décollages à bord
de soyouz qui va être de plus en plus
compliqué aujourd'hui ça paraît oui on
va la coopération auto la saison quand
ses intérêts avec la guerre en ukraine
elle et elle n'est pas interrompue il ya
encore des astronautes russes et des
astronautes américains à bord ça se
poursuit mais on voit mal
programme se prolonger très longtemps
surtout que la station elle arrive en
fin de vie donc c'est aussi une des
raisons pour lesquelles on a aujourd'hui
ce programme lunaire c'est pour donner à
la nasa une impulsion forte après
l'arrêt après le bal a forcément la fin
de la station mais la fin du financement
public de la station parce qu'il ya des
projets pour des financements privés des
entreprises qui seraient intéressés par
en faire une exploitation privée cette
citation d'henri alors on a 120 qui me
dis donc pour la mission finale on passe
de 2025 on devait envoyer des hommes
soit une admis la traque à 2030
j'imagine personne ne s'est en fait 2025
ça paraît pas très crédible parce que
starship donc tu as fait la fusée et le
vaisseau lourd 2
deux spécimens elon musk sont pas prêts
mais 2027 2028 j'en sais rien on verra
on verra
2005 c'était prévu pour être le
troisième vol d'artemis menacées dont
première mission artemis 1 avec des
mannequins d'andré capsule
deuxième mission si cela fonctionne bien
un vol habité l'église astronautes cette
fois on fait le tour de la lune mais on
n'y va pas rendre mais on se pose pas
mais on vérifie tous les systèmes qui
qui ont anticipé et le 3e vol ba c'est
la vraie mission lunaire à titre de
comparaison quand on regarde la ce qui
s'est passé pour apollo
il ya eu beaucoup plus de vols à vendre
avant le premier alunissage il y avait
la police est premier vol automatique
apollo 8 on met tout autour de la terre
avec des astronautes 9 10 des vols
autour de la lune
automatique apollo 11 le vrai tentative
l'alunissage donc là quelque part la
nasa un timing un peu plus agressif plus
ambitieux aussi avec juste trois
missions pour se poser sur la lune mais
après trois ans pour refaire trois
missions du coup oui c'était un peu plus
puisque trois ans parce que l'unmis un
vol en 2022 avant 2023 artemis 2 et un
volant 2025 pour artemis 3 donc pas de
vol en 2024 donc oui c'est comme un
rythme tranquille sylvain en termes
opérationnels pour le poker canaveral
c'est pas furieux à montaren et un peu
même moins peu - pourquoi est-ce-que on
retourne sur la lune on avait arrêté de
vouloir retard sur la lune et là on se
dit les américains se disent sayf il
faut y retourner alors la raison
officielle c'est la lune c'est le
meilleur tremplin avant d'aller plus
loin d'aller sur mars
si on est un peu cynique on regarde un
peu les annonces et on se voit que quand
trump annonce
artemis et 10,1 américains ou une
américaine va remettre le pied sur la
lune
c'est quelques semaines après l'annoncé
chinoise de leur programme lunaire
aiguisons nous on est prêt pour un
intérêt l'uni sage en 2030 donc là on
est on est dans une gare des symboles
salle à lui ne connaît qu'une course à
la lune un peu comme dans les années 60
avec une autre vie tic et les états unis
là c'est la chine qui est l'aiguillon
qui
il ya une forme de symboles ne pas
laisser les chinois
remarquez l'histoire en étant les
premiers retourner cinquante ans après
il ya
après c'est plus compliqué de justifier
la lune quand on disait voilà pour aller
sur mars ont d'abord la lune c'est
beaucoup plus proche un voyage vers la
lune avec avec sms c'est entre trois et
quatre jours un voyage vers mars ces six
mois on comprend que c'est mars c'est
vraiment beaucoup plus loin c'est
beaucoup plus complexe on sort du champ
magnétique terrestre qu'on a on est
exposé au vent solaire donc aux
bombardements des particules solaires
donc il ya un vrai enjeu de comment on
réduit les radiations prises par les
astronautes pour un vol de six mois est
ce qu'on leur fait des boucliers si on
fait les boucliers bas c'est à dire
quelque chose de lourd
coût lourde donc c'est plus à envoyer un
espace c'est plus coûteux et il ya il
faut plus de propulsion il faut
maintenant il faudra c'est une
nourriture pendant six mois il faut
enfin cesser les enjeux qui sont
vraiment une
beaucoup beaucoup plus complexe que les
sur la lune donc en revanche la fusée
elle peut resservir pour envoyer une
capsule
autour de la lune où tout la terre avant
de décoller vers plus loin donc la fusée
puissante elle elle servira toujours le
point commun entre les deux les lacets
la fusée et la capsule aussi mais est ce
que ces fusées alors parce qu'on l'a vu
avec les avec les fusées space x qui une
fois qu'elle partait elle se reposer
est-ce que là c'est ce qui va se passer
ce qui pourrait se passer ça avec sls en
a on a pris les éléments d'une fusée qui
avait été conçu pour être réutilisables
donc la navette spatiale elle a été
conçue pour être utilisable elle a été
remise à mais un coût extrêmement élevé
c'est une des raisons de l'échec des
problèmes navette c'est que ça coûte et
horriblement cher on parle de entre 500
millions et 1 milliard de dollars par
vol en fait il fallait intégralement
vérifier toutes les tuiles de protection
thermique des navettes il fallait
démonter les moteurs intégralement les
remontées de vérifier les remonter en
fait c'est presque construire un nouveau
moteur dans le démonter entièrement donc
il y avait on estime qu'il y avait dans
pour la navette dix mille personnes qui
travaillaient en continu pour remettre
pour vérifier et mettre à niveau les
navettes entre deux entre deux vols
dirait un coût qui était énorme donc là
on appris on a pris les éléments d'une
navette réutilisables pour en faire un
musée jetables
c'est pas trop non plus étant que ce
soit très cher mais quand on veut lancer
une fusée une fois tous les ans le
réutilisables ça sert à rien mais
c'est pas la même chose que ce qu'ils
effectuent et qu'effectivement ce qu'il
fasse un akp l'origine par l origine sp6
lors l'ambition c'est de faire vraiment
plusieurs lancements par semaine de
récupérer le premier étage qui revient
se poser à la verticale et qui est saisi
par des bras sur le pas de tir dont le
premier étage devrait très vite
directement se bâtir le deuxième étage
donc là le vaisseau starship lui-même
pareil se reposer à la verticale donc
être complètement réutilisables on
reprend l'un au rebond mais le vaisseau
là au sommet du premier étage on refait
les pleins et ont déjà schématise peut
utiliser ça l'idée on redécolle donc 6 p
6 arrive à faire ça on a on sa
révolution dresser clairement le
le lancement spatial et on serait plus
sur des budgets d'un milliard par
lancement pour diffuser l'euro mais non
il ya des choses qui sont inimaginables
aujourd'hui qui demande est possible
mais on en est pas encore là et voilà
enfin le
programme avance mais aujourd'hui donc
il faut patienter et attendre au moins
ou moins grande histoire pour revoir un
compte à rebours pour voir la chance de
peut être voir cette fusée magnifique et
géante décoller alors kris kross qui
indique l échec pour les américains et
les européens poutine l'exilim ping
doivent bien se marrer on rappelle c'est
pas forcément un échec c'est quelque
chose qui était prévu dans un report de
vol
ccc jamais un échec l'échec sur lequel
explosion si la navale et la nasa avait
procédé au lancement malgré la panne il
dit voilà il faut qu'on lance absolument
et que les fusils explose en vol la wii
c'est un échec c'est clairement un échec
mais un report de lancement de quelques
jours sont un programme qui est déjà en
retard depuis cinq ans je veux dire
vraiment pas grave c'est c'est quelque
chose qui est c'est pour ça qu'il ya un
compte à rebours en famille c'est pour
ça qu'il ya une procédure lancement qui
est hyper structuré où chaque minute
chaque opération et tout est détaillé
avec un planning très très très
c'est si c'est aussi organisé c'est pour
tout vérifier avant le moment où on
allume les moteurs et on envoie la fille
dans l'espace est donc temps que tant
que la fusion pas décollé c'est pas un
échec alors d'un internaute qui était
peut-être pas là au début alors on
allègue 12 min qu'ils demandent c'est
quand le lancement le lancement n'aura
pas lieu aujourd'hui il y aura lieu soit
vendredi soit lundi soit encore plus
tard si cela parce que et alors il ya
aussi une autre condition va peut-être
en parler parce qu'on le voit sur ces
images c'est la fenêtre météo parce que
les amplis plus en souvent oui oui la
fusée peut pas décoller sous la pluie
donc
et en plus en se pendant toute la nuit
le remplissage des réservoirs aussi a
été retardé à cause d'orages au large
avec l'avait classée 1ère c'est un
mauvais côté du report ça c'est que plus
on avance dans la saison plus on se
rapproche de la saison cyclonique un peu
identique sud et
les conditions vont être compliqués
peut-être compliqué un peu plus
compliqué en floride on y lit la côte
fleurie qu'il ya beaucoup de rage hélas
cette nuit il y avait
une ligne d'orages qui était au large de
la côte qui était pas au dessus de 4
caméras mais dans ces cas là très loin
et qui se rapprochait et qui a retardé
d'une heure et demie le début du
remplissage
voilà donc la météo c'est un facteur
hyper important avant d'ailleurs avant
que le lancement soit repoussé le laf le
voyant météo était passé du vert au
rouge toute façon et alors ils voient
pas les collègues voilà ils ont un peu
accumulé les choses qui pouvait mal se
passer on va dire série mais en même
temps c'est laisser les aléas qui sont
complètement pris en compte et est
connue prévisible voilà c'est pas c'est
pas une surprise le fait qu'il puisse
pleuvoir en floride pourquoi est ce que
la prochaine fenêtre météo la prochaine
fenêtre de lancement et vendredi et non
pas demain ou après demain alors je veux
dire c'est une très bonne question je
n'ai pas complètement la réponse donc
voilà c'est maintenant fait c'est qu'il
ya entre
c'est première fois qu'on est fusillé
cette fusée est prête au décollage n'a
eu le remplissage et a été presque
presque fini presque terminé et donc à
2000 tonnes
de d'hydrogène liquide et d'oxygène
liquide à vide et on vide les réservoirs
après ça il y aura d'autres
vérifications en fait enfin c'est le
sait le temps à tout remettre en place
tout remettront en fonctions pour un
nouveau complice âge s'assurer que le
faire faire un reset de la fusée pour la
ram est au même point comme été et c'est
ça qui prend du temps mais j'ai pas j'ai
pas la réponse unique sur la l'origine
de la pourquoi et pourquoi il faut
autant de jours que pour ça je donc
voile riders qui me demandent dans
combien de temps le lancement et bien
pas aujourd'hui du coût de lancement
aura lieu vendredi lundi ou plus tard si
le problème n'est pas n'est pas résolu
voit la syrie demande est rappelé que le
problème c'est le refroidissement d'un
des quatre moteurs et voilà sous corps
central ya quatre gros moteurs des
moteurs qu'ils étaient des moteurs de la
navette spatiale qui sont réutilisés
pour cette fusée est avant les allumer
il faut les refroidir et parce que le
carburant qui les petits les propulser
extrêmement froid hydrogène liquide et
d'oxygène liquide donc on n'allume pas
un moteur à chaud et un des quatre
moteurs n'a
n'a pas été correctement refroidis par
une circle line on devait faire circuler
de l'hydrogène à très basse température
alors on à tony poncet qui nous
demandent à quoi va servir cette cette
mission cette mission peut être voir ce
photographe y fait par le service
infographie du figaro on peut expliquer
rapidement à quoi va servir la voyait le
un lacet le petit décollage on va se
faire un petit tour de la ville à basse
altitude en plus bas n'ont pas si bas ça
le dise que ça enfin le
l'objectif de la mission s'est testé la
fusée qui n'a jamais volé donc
la fusée la plus puissante au décollage
depuis depuis sept jours de 5 des
missions lunaires
apollo
ça c'est le premier point et c'est aussi
tester la capsule sur un voyage de
longue durée puisque la mission va durer
quarante deux jours donc on voit la
trajectoire qu'on commence par
trajectoires verte sur l'image et
collages de cap canaveral
là c'est le gros du travail il est fait
par le corps central de la fusée donc
les quatre moteurs et les deux boosters
à poudre qui sont blancs qui sont de
part et d'autre de la fusée
au bout d'une heure et demie on arrive
au point deux injections transfert c'est
que là le la capsule est déjà en orbite
autour de la terre mais il faut la
sortir de l'attraction terrestre elle a
envoyé vers vers la lune ça c'est la vie
qui sont 30 lunaire c'est là où il ya
une
poussée en tant que deuxième étage qui
doit encore fonctionner et donner une
poussée suffisante une vitesse
suffisante pour ces derniers de la terre
on a une mise en orbite autour de la
lune c'est le point 6
6 norbit rétrograde quand les trop grade
qu'est ce que ça veut dire déjà rétro
vas tu sais que c'est le sens contraire
à la lah à la rotation de l'astre place
autour de la terre d'accord c'est entre
s'ils tournent dans le sens horaire ça
va tourner dans le sens antihoraire pas
les
détails c'est pas très grave donc on a
un survol de la lune à 100 km et après
une orbite autour de la lune mais qui
veille qui va aller s'éloigner
vraiment loin et ça va amener le
vaisseau orion la capsule orion à plus
de 400 milles kilomètres 450 mille
kilomètres de la terre donc ses joues
moins qu'aucune capsule habitable
jusqu'ici donc
si la mission elle pourra se faire de
manière beaucoup plus courtes donc 42
jours c'est aussi pour tester le
fonctionnement des systèmes de la
capsule pour une mission longue
on a dit que on voit sous la capsule sur
les dessins
quatre panneaux solaires ces quatre
panneaux solaires ils sont c'est le
module de service qui est fournie par
l'europe donc c'est là c'est la
contribution européenne à la mission
c'est ça qui fournit l'électricité qui
fournissent l'oxygène aux astronautes
de voilà de l'eau et tout ce dont ils
ont besoin pour faire fonctionner leurs
capsules
c'est à dire que cette c'est la capsule
orion va partir assez loin est-ce qu'on
pourrait la perdre à ce moment là pareil
oui oui il ya enfin la perdre je pense
pas non mais il ya une
[Musique]
moment il faut quitter l'orbité lunaire
donc c'est le point 8 son image dans
bleu tout emballé du schéma et c'est là
il faut encore une poussée des moteurs
pour revenir vers la terre et là le
dessin complètement juste à 6,6 fait
pendant ces années les sages dans le
pacifique avec l'amerrissage il est
prévu au large de san diego donc au
large des côtes californiennes à une
vitesse très élevée on rien de la lune
donc on a une vitesse hyper élevé on est
beaucoup plus et beaucoup plus rapide
qu'une capsule qui devrait prendre la
session passée l'international
ça c'est un des difficultés du
développement de la capsule orion elle a
un gros bouclier qui est très épais
trait qui va qui va voir qui va chauffer
très très fort
donc ça c'est là la dernière partie qui
partit du de l'essai du test de cette
mission c'est l'amerrissage
d'abord rentrer dans l'atmosphère donc
très rapidement qu'un faux réchauffement
et après ba3 parachute qui vont s'ouvrir
et ralentir la capsule avant qu'il se
pose en douceur on l'espère
dans l'océan ces images qu'on se
rappelle qu'on accorde à cette terrible
et c'est à des missions les images des
missions apollo on voit les hélicoptères
récupérer les autres dans l'eau la
capsule qui flotte on va revoir assez
vite c'est genre d'image dans une
question juste prix de bovary qui
demandent cette annulation va-t-elle
avoir des retombées économiques
importantes
non non non ça change ça change rien de
lancer à deux ou trois jours de
différence
ça va ça va surtout un impact pour les
journalistes qui sont sur place et qui
vont devoir
déplacer leur pied de l'avion de retour
et que je sais sur place leur est plus
longtemps mais oui et la ville pour le
programme e dans un champ de ruines et
puis on parle des juristes mais aussi
tous les personnes toutes les personnes
qui étaient parce qu'on parlait quand
même entre 100 et 200 mille personnes
floride oui il ya quand même
au moins cent mille déçus qu'ils étaient
des américains qui sont qui ont fait le
déplacement
qui n'avait pas d'accréditation pour
être sur le centre spatial kennedy de la
nasa mais qui en fait quand on est sur
les plages aux alentours ou alors il ya
là il ya une ville qui est proche
s'appelle titusville si elle il ya des
ponts et des qui sont assez proches du
pas de tir on voit la fusée au loin il
faut que c'est quand même une vingtaine
de kilomètres mais oui mon voisin fusée
aussi puissante quand elle décolle même
20 km ça fait un bruit incroyable donc
c'est un spectacle qui avait été
anticipé par au moins cinq mille
américains eux je pense que voilà la
déception est grande puisque lundi matin
ils ont dû prendre leur journée ils ont
passé toute la semaine peut-être pour
revoir vendredi si ça décolle vendredi
bien sûr djoko ce qu'ils demandent
pourquoi avoir appelé la capsule orion
très bonne question très bien sûr voilà
nous n'avons pas la réponse à toutes les
questions vous pouvez essayer de
retrouver ça doit sûrement être quelque
part sur le figaro on s'en fait pas trop
cyril dont on parlait de ça tout à
l'heure effectivement mais et les
chinois ils vont quand sur la lune aussi
être dans leurs projets oui mais les
chinois ont un programme qui est un peu
le double de ce que ce que je fais là
noz à celle qu'ils ont aussi une fusée
lourde qui en met plein développement
qui s'appelle longue marche 9 qui est
une fusée vraiment de la catégorie
saturn 5 donc la fusée lunaire des
années 60
capable d'envoyer 130 tonnes en orbite
autour de la terre je crois de mémoire
et 50 tonnes autour de la lune dont 4
est très très gros bébé par l aps 800
mètres de haut
cette fusée est en cours de
développement on a peu d'informations
ont sacré chinois non qu'ils annoncent
un vol 2030
ils vont à leur rythme les chinois en
fait ils ont ils ont pas de chiffres pas
et quadrillée comme par exemple la pub a
pu faire donald trump pour justement but
nantais voilà le programme chinois il
est défini par des parrains comité
central d'experts machin il est prévu
dix ans à l'as vence
la chine elle a mis un temps fou avant
d'envoyer son premier astronaute dans
l'espace ils ont misé en t ils ont
beaucoup progressé et ils vont en large
à leur rythme à izon en ce moment autour
de la terre une station est un peu le
corps le lait qui ont du coeur de la
station spatiale nationale des modules
un module habitable dans lequel ils
peuvent envoyer des astronautes quand
ils veulent
après la voilà la lune il faut une fusée
très grosse il faut en a dit tout à
l'heure il faut beaucoup de vitesse pour
arriver à se mettre quitté attraction
terrestre et se mette en orbite autour
de la lune
voilà donc là ils construisent de la
fabrication de refuser lourde qui va
probablement être très très cher elle
aussi mais ça fait partie du plan et
voilà et le plan en chine il est lancé
il est financé
qui d'après il n'y a pas de raison qu'il
n'y arrive pas et ils ont ils ont en
tout cas toutes les compétences pour le
faire et pour y arriver donc je dis ça
soit 2030 ou 2032 j'en sais rien mais ce
genre de timing pour les chinois il est
totalement crédible et
en tout cas c'est ça qui met un peu la
pression des américains louis petit feu
et puisqu'il faurecia lancées pions
l'idée alors restons bien parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui me posent des
questions qu'ils aient on peut dire
merci au président en train pour cette
mission est ce que c'est gras savoye à
trump que les états unis retourne sur la
lune oui c'est c'est
c'est donald trump qui a lancé programme
artémise qui a mis aussi un
une chronologie un timing intenable la
nasa lui voulait un retour sur la lune
en 2024 il annonça en 2019 en cinq ans
la fusée avait pas encore volé je
n'étais pas prête mal comment c'était
possible n'y avait pas de vaisseau pour
atterrir sur une
voie là la première étape c'est que
cette fusée lourdes géante elle va voler
à peut-être pas voulu aujourd'hui parce
que voilà un problème sur l'un des trois
des quatre moteurs mais elle va voler
et bientôt ça c'est sûr donc voilà les
la nasa progresse et même si le timing
de données par donald trump n'était pas
crédible au moins ça avance et joe biden
quand il a pris ses fonctions il n'a pas
annulé le programme c'est un peu une on
a vu ça depuis une quinzaine d'années en
fait il est président a annoncé l'un un
programme vers la lune vers mars un
programme vers la lune obama vers les
astéroïdes et puis le suisse arrive il
change les plans il y à nouveau patron
de la nasa la banda n'a pas trop changé
fusée était presque terminée et celle là
elle est presque terminée le gros du
budget est déjà financée et puis il a il
a choisi on le voit on l'a vu à l'image
brillamment au jim brennan stein patron
de la nasa qui est interviewé par nasa
tv qui est ici et qui est un ancien
sénateur qui était je t'aime je te dire
une bêtise la floride en fait il est
sénateur dans des états qui est le plus
impliqué dans le programme spatial
américain ou manière historique et il ya
quelques étapes 1 quel nom notamment des
états dans lequel la floride c'est
logique c'est là où sont lancées les
fusées
mais il ya aussi l'alabama construit les
courts centraux des spéciales il y avait
mais c'est un vrai plus à l'épaule pour
l'économie américaine la californie qui
construisent c'est des gros mots du mais
il y avait un état dans lequel se
construit les booster et tout ça c'est
des représentants de ces états là ici
âge la commission du sénat
donc on imagine qu'ils sont pas très
envie de les couper voilà donc
il n'a pas coupé le preneur mais on est
là premier vol qui se rapproche pour les
crs voilà qui n'aura pas lieu
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle pourquoi le
lancement a été
retardé à leur demande est déjà l'eau
qui ce qu'ils demandaient ce que la
capsule va se poser sur la lune pas
encore non on va passer à 100 km au
dessus mais pas encore est ce qu on peut
rappeler pourquoi est-ce que le
lancement a été retardé à vendredi cyril
oui oui il ya eu il ya eu un un compte à
rebours qui a été interrompue pendant un
bon bout de temps parce que
[Musique]
les ingénieurs n'ont pas réussi à
refroidir un des quatre moteurs
principaux de la fusée sont des moteurs
qui fonctionnent à l'hydrogène liquide
et à l'oxygène liquide et avant de les
mettre à feu il faut absolument qu'il
soit refroidi on parle de température de
moins 200 degrés donc
ils ont pas réussi à faire circuler de
l'hydrogène dans ce moteur sur un des
quatre moteurs donc il vaut mieux être
refroidis et il ya un risque d'explosion
et donc du coup on ne décolle pas et
l'objectif annoncé de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé et voir comment on peut
développer le problème d'ici vendredi
d'après dizaines de tirs on l'a dit
vendredi on a alors on va bientôt
arrêter cela y va parce que ça fait déjà
40 minutes que nous sommes en direct et
le lancement n'aura pas lieu il faut
quand même que siri d'un journal à faire
donc il faut que je libère quand même
kriss kross qu'ils ne vendent quand même
quid des indiens et des russes dans le
dans le spatial alors les russes c'est
assez triste
en fait ils vivent sur leurs acquis les
acquis l'union soviétique et depuis la
chute de l'union soviétique un fait il
ya eu les peu de développement de
nouveaux lanceurs de nouveaux nouvelles
missions
et ça prend un temps fou
donc les astronautes russes ils
décollent toujours à la saison passée
nationale à bord de fusées soyouz qui
sont diffusées qui ont des vues de leur
histoire dans les années cinquante et
une capsule conçu dans les années 60
c'est été modernisé depuis
la russie travaille sur une fusée en
gare à qui est prévu pour remplacer ça
mais qui est pas encore en
fonctionnement et on voit pas vu le
manque de financement russes dans leur
secteur spatial pas de développement
crédible en fait en tout cas pour
retourner sur la lune ou encore moins à
retourner vers mars et au programme
russe il est un peu il est un peu en
stand by il est
dans le d'une ornière il n'arrive pas à
sortir aussi beaucoup de corruption
partie des financements apparemment qui
sont détournés ce qui était le cas pour
la construction d'un nouveau pas de tir
dans l'est de la russie et la pologne
l'inde ya des ambitions qui sont
peut-être moins grandes mais là on
travaille aujourd'hui pour envoyer un
premier astronaute indien dans une
capsule abord une fusée indienne autour
de la terre on n'est pas encore sur la
lune
il faut rappeler aussi que le prix
d'entrée pour pour faire du spatial
c'est quand même extrêmement cher on
parle de budget là on parle de budget
artemis orient 20 milliards chacun 40
milliards pour ce programme déjà dépensé
simple déjà dépensé jusqu'à la fin du
programme on estime ses 90 milliards au
total qui seront dépensés jusqu'à la fin
des programmes artemis donc oui c'est
affreusement chez est en fait une raison
pour laquelle les c'est tellement cher
c'est que les vols habités
on n'a pas le droit à l'échec avec les
lanceurs c'est aussi pour ça que le
cette mission de tester les six
importantes avec artemis milliers
personnes à bord mais heureusement c'est
pour tester la fusée tester tous les
systèmes est sûr que quand on enverra
des astronautes ont fonctionné
correctement et en a et donc il ya un
surcoût énorme sur les vérifications de
sécurité pour tous les systèmes c'est
vrai pour la fusée c'est vrai aussi pour
la capsule c'est vrai pour le module de
service qui vous fournit l'électricité
qui est donc que donne que fournit
l'europe l'agent spatiale européenne et
tout ça ça fait que les coûts sont
en plus il faut une fusée géante capable
d'envoyer là c'est plus de 100 tonnes en
orbite donc cesser c'est quelque chose
de vraiment extrêmement complexe qui
pousse en fait toutes les techniques à
leurs limites en fait c'est irigny
simple donc le vol habité déjà même
envoyer des astronautes sur la station
spatiale internationale c'est vraiment
compliqué vraiment difficile on rappelle
que l'europe on n'est pas capable
l'europe n'a pas de capacité d'envoyer
des astronautes par ses propres moyens
vers espace voilà il que et que la chine
les etats unis la russie aujourd'hui
qu'ils en sont capables donc voilà le
la lune c'est très difficile c'est que
c'est compliqué et il faudrait avoir
effectivement comment comment ça se
passe
pour ces nations aussi voilà pour cette
histoire t il on rappelle du coup ce qui
s'est passé c'est que le le lancement de
cette fusée a été reportée soit vendredi
soir lundi donc on vous donne rendez
vous pour ce lancement bon l'histoire
vendredi soir 18 heures on prend rendez
vous si je dis cela parce que c'est
possible aussi que vendredi matin
vendredi midi on nous dise ce sera pas
du tout vendre est ce que c'est possible
ça 2 2 d'annuler complètement une lettre
de lens moyens oui c'est la nasa trouve
pas une solution pour débloquer
l'alimentation en hydrogène du
refroidissement du moteur 3 où il n'y
aura pas deux il y aura même pas début
de contrat vous
après jeu mais je n'ai sens
connaissant la nasa ils vont imaginer
moi je pense qu'ils vont imaginer
quelque chose ils vont imaginer
procédure et qui vont la tester pendant
le compte à rebours s'est déjà refaire
un compte à rebours c'est aussi une
répétition déjà deux procédures qui sont
complexes et voilà donc c'est s'est
jamais perdu un boulot tout ce qui s'est
passé pendant la nuit le remplissage
j'ai pas mal d'incidents dont on n'a pas
parlé il ya eu
une petite fuite sur un moment une un
branchement d'hydrogène sur le réservoir
il ya des petits aléas sont des choses
pendant lesquelles les ingénieurs et ils
apprennent bien d'autres choses donc en
fait ils sont en train aussi de
d'affiner leur compréhension du lanceur
de la manière dont qui tout ça
fonctionne et ce quel lanceur ans vont
nous on voit que la partie émergée on
voit là la fusée d'un kg et qui est
énorme cent mètres de haut des 1600
tonnes elle ne fonctionne que parce
qu'il ya un pas de tir il ya une
alimentation en carburant
c'est cryogénique donc c'est moins 250
degrés on peut c'est du temps perdu où
tout est compliqué en famille mais tout
ça tout ça c'est les opérations qui sont
complexes qui sont difficiles et la nasa
a maîtrisé sur les navettes spatiales et
là on est sur un engin qui est vraiment
nouveau qui est quand même assez
différent il faut tout réapprendre donc
je même un compte à rebours il est
interrompu il va pas jusqu'au bout pour
les ingénieurs la nasa c'est un
apprentissage qui était cette équipe est
exceptionnelle et qui sera pas perdue du
tout et je veux juste montrer cette
piste image peut-être puisque c'est ça
dont parlait ce pas de tir oui on
déplace vers le tir mobile sur des
grosses chenilles et qui se déplace sur
un chemin de gravier qui était le sait
même pas tu y as mobile qui emmenait sa
fusée saturn 5 20 repas tiercé même
pâtir et c'est aussi le pas de tir
mobile qui étaient modifiées depuis mai
qui emportait les navettes spatiales
depuis le grand hangar convoi en gare
blanc ce qui s'appelle le vab véhicules
assemblés building qui était pendant un
moment le plus gros building sur terre
150 mètres de haut et non
oui gigantesque on imagine et il faut
emmener tout ça il faut emmener les
quelques centaines de tonnes vers le pas
de tir et
et si ça décolle pas le 5 mai il faudra
ramener le lanceur versons langueur
faire pas mal de vérification avant de
trouver une autre date de lancement et
donc retenter de retenter à ce moment là
effectivement voilà effet lâche antoine
c'est quand le lancement ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui c'est soit vendredi soit
lundi soit plus tard on le disait si ça
ne marche pas merci à vous vendre
commercy syrie d'avoir été avec nous
mais pour cela je vais vous laisser
maintenant conduit à faire votre journal
quand même puisque nous pas trop vous
vous prendre du temps mais on se donne à
peu près à mon avis rendez vous vendredi
on va dire qu'on donne rendez-vous pour
ça sans histoire 18h48 c'est l'heure
prévue pour le décollage de ce deuxième
tentative
mais on sera là pour vivre ça en direct
moi je vous dis à bientôt pour de
nouveaux lives sur figaro l'est